but this latest variant might be the
best it's
[Music]
10.5
covid-19 as a ride it's a new strain but
it isn't the same
everybody how are you what's going on
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben rip
word and before I tell you anything else
about what's going on in the world I
want to tell you that Today's show you
know yesterday I did a lot of Cali
versus Florida stuff and at the end of
the show I was like you know I think
I've made the point I've made the point
we're going to continue making the point
and and the contrast and the comparison
is important to do but we finished the
show yesterday I thought I want to do
something a little bit different
tomorrow I sense we can try something
for a little bit something just a little
bit different a little bit let's give
the people some juice let's not just
talk about how bad things are in Cali
and just say how great things are
Florida let's go across the country and
find some good things so that's exactly
what we are doing today uh before we get
to any of that though uh we've been
putting up these shorts uh YouTube is
going very heavy on shorts which are
like these like 30 to 40 45 50 55 second
videos that you can put up there and we
have a shelf now on our YouTube channel
for these shorts and we did this one
yesterday this is off the Bill Gates
video we showed you yesterday where Bill
Gates was talking about how good the
government is and the good government's
there to keep you safe and all that
stuff so we put one up and I wanted to
just throw to that real quick for you uh
just to remind you that these shorts are
available and people are viewing them
and enjoying them here you go why and
how ready should we be for the next
pandemic the pandemic is a disaster that
they didn't prepare for the idea of uh
improving the vaccines so that they
block
getting infection making them so they
last a long long time governments are
there to protect us
the president promised help is on the
way and today help has arrived the
nine most terrifying words in the
English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to help
good old Ronald Reagan good old Ronald
Reagan anyway if you want to see more of
our shorts you can go to the Shelf which
is at youtube.com Reuben report we put
them up on Instagram too they're on
Rumble they're everywhere just a little
little something for it so now we're
going to focus today really on positive
stuff because there is a lot of positive
stuff one of the things that is
happening is a guy by the name of Byron
Donalds who I mentioned yesterday he's a
congressman out of Southwest Florida
he's got the Fort Myers Naples Sanibel
Captiva area that is the area that was
crushed by Hurricane Ian he is suddenly
becoming a star in Republican politics
I've interviewed him you may have seen
the interview he did it about a month
and a half ago down or up I guess now I
guess I'm in Florida now up in D.C he's
a really good dude I think he's fighting
for the right things and he's becoming a
star right now not only because the
Republicans nominate him to be speaker
right so you got to think 19 votes
obviously It ultimately went to McCarthy
but that kind of leveled him up in the
in the National scene but he's going
to MSNBC and fighting with those
dingbats and we got a whole bunch of
clips of him and Joy Reed on MSNBC and
it is wild but that is indicative Byron
Donald's rise is indicative of I think
there's a chance right now with the
Republicans I I am not deluded I don't
as I always say they'll probably fail
you they're going to screw up all sorts
of things they're better than the
Democrats fine but I think there is a
chance right now for them to get a
backbone like a ramrod as a certain guy
is one to say but I think there is a
maturing strengthening of the Republican
Party spine right now and we got to
encourage them we got to show the ones
that are doing good say like that Rhonda
said this guy hey you're doing good I'm
gonna vote for you so that's what we're
going to be focusing on today it's a lot
of good markers of positivity there's
going to be a lot of Clips out of the
show today that you're going to be able
to send to your friends and who are
depressed about what's going on and
there's a lot of problems you know you
live in California and they're coming
from my natural gas and they want me to
wear a mask and all those things and
you'll be able to say hey watch this
because there are places where it's
actually working uh before we do that
let me talk to you guys about bullying
Max real quick see quick you know 2022
was the worst year for the stock market
since 2008. let's go Brandon what does
2023 hold and do you really want all
your eggs in that basket get Diversified
in your assets and you can do that at
booleanmax.com Dave at bullionmax.com
Dave you can buy physical gold and
silver bars and coins and they'll ship
them directly to your home fully insured
there you can store them in your safe
for a time you might really need it you
have fire extinguishers at your house
that are easy to reach to prevent your
house from burning down you hope you
never have to use one but you'll be
grateful you have one if the worst
should happen what if your financial
house burns down if paper money becomes
worthless if the stock market it
completely collapses
wouldn't it be nice to have something
for emergencies start building your
Reserve at booleanmax.com Dave we put
together a silver starter kit just for
you listen to this you're going to get a
solid one ounce silver American Eagle a
buffalo round even a one ounce silver
kangaroo this is the best way to get to
start diversifying your savings go to
booleanmax.com Dave and now back to me
okay so I have to show you one thing
that you're gonna go wait a minute Dave
you said it's all positive today and
you're gonna go why are you showing me a
clip from The View but you're going to
see why it's a positive clip just trust
me on this one so the view yesterday
they were talking about these documents
that have been found that Joe Biden had
some classified documents that were in a
closet somewhere and yes they were
related to Ukraine and Russia and Iran
but he didn't know anything the guy
doesn't know anything remember when in
August when this happened to Trump you
know this is impeachment nine even
though he's not president anymore and
he's going to finally go to jail and
they've got him and the walls are
closing in anyway the view covered
Biden's classified documents being found
and listen to the way Joy Behar frames
it and then you'll see she starts
talking about Byron Donalds that's going
to get us to the what really is going on
here situation
not good well we all know that Trump is
a liar and a thief you know
bigger jump to say that he obstructed
and he lied we don't think that Biden is
a liar and a thief so we give him the
benefit of the doubt that's probably
what's going on but what I think also is
going on no matter what the truth of it
is will be they will spin it bubble head
and Marjorie Taylor and that crowd Matt
Gates you think they're not going to
spin this that is just as bad as Trump
and so the the LIE gets out there as
people believe it just like that
Donaldson person whatever his name is
what's his name Byron Donald's I saw him
also he was at the uh the fight on the
floor too he was nominated for speaker
has been so invasive
and it's just a mirror it's just a
mirror Joy all you need and is a mirror
and you'll figure out what's going on
here everything she accuses the
Republicans of doing is exactly what
she's doing now uh she makes a point
that there are differences there are
differences between these two things uh
one difference Joy might be that the
president is allowed to declassify
documents the vice president is not
allowed to that is a legitimate uh
difference in what's going on here
that's one thing but I don't think
that's exactly what she meant by it also
the way that you know the way that the
audience applies Trump is a liar and a
con man and oh my God yes yes as if
Biden is somehow like the the true gold
standard of Truth and everything else if
you get these vaccines you're not going
to get or transmit covet remember when
the elderly man said that uh then they
start shifting to Byron Donald's and
here's really where I want to shift the
show as long as we're talking about
shifting Byron Donalds was nominated in
the midst of this fight for the
speakership he was nominated I think in
one round he got about 19 votes there
was a real feeling like oh this guy
could be he's young he's extremely
bright well spoken has a good pedigree
he's doing a great job here in a state
that's absolutely flourishing it's like
maybe this guy could be something so I
don't know that they thought uh that he
was going to actually become speaker
that somehow he was going to get all the
votes and McCarthy was going to lose 200
votes but it it's an opportunity to
level up some people get people in
mainstream media corporate press as
irrelevant as they may be becoming get
them to start talking about these guys
and then Byron Pro Byron Donald's
profile starts Rising
and then you never know what the future
might hold this is how politics works so
Sunny Hostin calls him he's the new
darling of the Republican party you may
have heard her say that it's interesting
when she says that though because the
way she's saying it is the implication
is he's the darling because he's their
token black guy and as you guys know
there is no racism quite like
Progressive racism so now I want to show
you why Sunny might be right but for the
wrong reasons he might be the new
darling of the Republican party but it's
not just because he's some token black
guy okay it's because the guy knows what
he's doing and what he's talking about
cue Byron Donald talking to Wolf Blitzer
who I'm told is not actually a wolf I
just found that out this morning about
the Biden document situation thanks so
much for joining us let me get your
reaction to the breaking news uh uh you
know you're a member of Congress you
deal with classified information what's
your reaction to this oh well my
reaction is pretty simple I'm wondering
why the vice president of the United
States had classified documents outside
of the hands of the intelligence
Community listen it's been pretty clear
that presidents do have some classified
documents but the difference between a
president and everybody else is the
president has the ability to declassify
information the vice president has no
ability to declassify information so
number one what was he doing with
classified information in his possession
number two why did it take six years and
I want to stress this for the American
people Joe Biden left the vice
presidency in 2017. so it's taken six
years for these documents to surface
that is incredibly concerning and point
number three and this is the one that's
most important I everybody can go back
to the Hillary Clinton email Saga we
know other presidents have had
classified information but why was there
a rate on Mar-A-Lago but now this story
just kind of seeps out and everybody's
saying oh we just want to get down to
the bottom of it and everybody's giving
the benefit of the doubt a vice
president of the United States or a
secretary of state or anybody else
should not be having classified
information
well Sunny hoston do you think he's the
darling of the Republican party just
because he's black or do you think it's
because he's an extremely good
communicator has a great handle on
what's going on here knows what he's
talking about and isn't afraid to say it
later on guys go back into that video
and watch you can see Wolf Blitzer he's
so depressed hearing truth at his his
face is actually starts to slide off his
skull anyway Byron Donald's just
continued yesterday he had an All-Star
day he went on the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and not only
did he go there he went with in right
into the office with the chief crazy
lady he went to Joy Reed and they talked
about everything so we're going to show
you a whole bunch of Clips here and just
watch just watch this master class in
professionalism
knowledge Candor decency communication
the whole freaking thing that Byron
Donalds puts on and then compare that to
him Julie Reed behaves as a host here's
the first clip of them talking about the
Twitter files you've got Jim Jordan
who's leading Judiciary leading a
subcommittee to prove the quote
weaponization of the federal government
and also it seems possible that it might
be about going after the justice
department for investigating the
Insurrection that Jim Jordan supported
well a couple of things first and
foremost let's speak to the the
weaponization committee of the federal
government we see what's happening at
Twitter Twitter now is releasing
documentation dream after REM afterim
that elements of our government was
actually in contact with Twitter about
delisting comments taking people off of
Twitter off of Twitter overall if that
is not the federal government actually
suppressing free speech in the United
States which is the first amendment of
of the United States Constitution
Congress has a responsibility to
investigate
yeah that's right I think we've been
talking about that on this show if the
government forces or influences a
private company or a public company to
infringe on your free speech that
actually is a violation of the First
Amendment so there okay she sat and
listened she sat and listened but it's
the way she frames everything right Jim
Jordan was for the Insurrection right
yeah yeah the Insurrection where nobody
brought any weapons the only person
killed was one of them you know the
whole they had no plans some guy
apparently bought a Lego set and then it
turned out to be a different Lego set of
the capital and something else okay fine
they continued here they are Joy Reid
really she's very upset about what's
going on here in Florida right she can't
have it get out there that if you do the
right thing you could win by 20 points
like Ron DeSantis would or you'd win in
a landslide like Marco Rubio did so she
has to somehow this woman who does not
care about voter ID laws because she
thinks that they're racist doesn't want
people to have to show up with an ID or
anything else she has to somehow make it
seem like Florida is up to no good when
it comes to elections on voting laws you
voted you
once aren't you defend voting laws that
said getting rid of ballot harvesting is
a good thing that we did leave defended
the Florida voting laws
um and you've actually falls in the
country the Florida voting election laws
are the best election laws Arizona go as
California go as New York we do it the
best okay look Joy Reid she does not
want transparent voting laws she doesn't
want people to have IDs she wants ballot
harvesting and all those things so they
can do their Shenanigans there is nobody
please find somebody serious I will
gladly interview them there is simply
nobody with a shred of Integrity that is
saying that there is anything wrong with
the Florida voting system it is it is
beautiful and a joy to partake in and I
tell you that as someone that walked
into a school showed my ID looked the
woman in the eye they look at you they
compare everything they check where you
live you walk over to the machine you
have a piece of paper it goes into the
machine the paper comes out you walk
over to a Ballot Box another person
looks at you confirms you're the same
person drop it in there we are results
came in at like seven o'clock there was
simply no doubt because we've done it in
a mature honest functional way here but
that's the scariest thing to Democrats
right that is the scariest thing and for
some reason Joy Reed thinks that black
people can't get ideas she should have
turned to Byron Donald's been like wait
you're black and you have an ID how the
hell did you pull that off
anyway she of course did get into the uh
the racist stuff and it's just it's just
it never stops it never stops with these
people if you are if you are black and
you think differently they think you are
a token because they are racist do you
not believe that the idea was to make a
diversity statement by nominating it
well actually first that was not the
idea because I was in the room when the
decision was made by people who chose to
nominate me that never came and you
you're still not explained how how your
profit you've never been in leadership
are you gonna let me answer your
questions okay number two now let's go
back the reality is is that a lot of
members actually do believe in my
ability to lead they do am I to be
despised from my youth because I've
served one term my members know that I
have the ability to engage other members
through the conference but it's even
bigger than that listen we were at an
impasse last week in our in our
speakership elections we got that done
Kevin McCarthy is now speaker of the
house at the same time I was working
with members on both sides of our
conference to make sure that we can get
the job done and we did
got to understand this guys she only
brought him on for one reason which was
to take him out and he was freaking
prepared and ready to roll and the gall
of her to sit across from somebody who
clearly knows what he's doing knows why
he is there is respected by his
colleagues just got 19 votes from the
supposed racist people as he said he was
in the room when it was happening you
think they were all like guys grab the
black guy
but she's only there to destroy him and
instead she's self-immolating right
she's self-flagellating she's pouring
the gasoline on herself and burning
herself up because she is the racist she
only views him as a black man and she
thinks black people must think these
things I think these five things I think
them now I've come to these conclusions
black people better think of guess what
I know this is old school I think black
people can think all sorts of things I
think individuals regardless of their
skin color or their genitals can think
all sorts of things it doesn't mean that
they're right about all of those things
but you can think all sorts of things
she thinks Democrats own black people
which to me would be a form of modern
slavery but okay uh it's interesting
though because I'm fairly certain she's
interviewed gay Pete uh Pete butterjudge
who is our transportation secretary and
I don't think she ever said were you
hired because you were gay gay Pete
because gay Pete you were the mayor of
South Bend Indiana and I don't see how
that would qualify you for anything
related to the transportation secretary
every job but you are gay so did she
ever she never did that ironically
related to gay Pete I don't know if you
heard this but the FAA grounded all
domestic flights this morning he's in
charge of the whole freaking thing he's
mostly on vacation he is completely
unqualified but he is gay Zippity
Dippity uh did she ever sit down with
the Phoenix you'll have to do some
research on this I got a couple others
here we have our uh Rachel Levine who
was formerly dick Levine who's our trans
Deputy Health secretary do you think
that might have been a diversity hire
Joy Reid did you ever have dick Levine
on task him or her why she or he was
hired we also have noted black lesbian
press secretary Corinne Jean-Pierre who
is by far the most completely
incompetent buffoon in all of the
government do you think that her black
lesbianism that tokenism do you think
that's why she got hired or was it
because of her awesome resume and the
awesome job she's doing or how about
Kamala Harris do you think she was hired
because she's just great really is a
great command of things you know Russia
big Ukraine small or is it it because
she's half black and pretends to
celebrate Kwanzaa or how about Dylan
movie
[Laughter]
I can't these people Dylan Mulvaney the
dude with the Wang who dresses up like a
chick and goes on Tick Tock and then
gets invited to the White House and then
has Biden sit there and tell you that
it's it's a moral imperative that
everyone every kid who wants to chop off
their nuts gets to go ahead what the
hell am I even talking about anymore you
see what they've done to us anyway Byron
Donald's continued he just it was just
it's a master class master class uh here
he is she's very upset Joy Reed she's
very upset because Kevin McCarthy is is
following through on his promises just
three days into this freaking thing he
is booting ilhan Omar Adam Schiff and
swalwell off a bunch of committees
intelligence committees and much more uh
and there's plenty of good reasons to do
it I mean can you think of anyone who
has lied more over the last couple years
than than Adam Schiff uh swalwell we've
got video of it I'm going to show you in
a sec I mean he's banging a Chinese spy
and everyone knows it and ilhan Omar is
is a rate like an old-fashioned old
school racist anti-Semitic cnx next
Tuesday here's Byron Donald explaining
why uh McCarthy did what he did three
people including Congressman swalwell
ilhan Omar and Adam Schiff have been
take are being taken off their
committees well we told Democrat
leadership when they went down this this
pathway of removing members from
committee is basically saying you should
not do that because if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander let's be
very clear Elon Omar has said things
that are reprehensible hold on hold on
hold on let me finish she has said
terrible things about about the Jewish
community so much so that resolutions
had to go to the house floor about them
and they were watered down with respect
to Eric swalwell and to the other
gentlemen that's something for speaker
McCarthy to speak to in more detail
because he's going to make those
decisions but we were very clear in the
117th Congress we should not be going
down this pathway of saying oh that
member said this they got to be kicked
off of committees
why they fear this guy he knows exactly
what he's talking about and he's got
receipts and it's true when they started
doing this a couple years ago when
Democrats started saying we're going to
kick certain Republicans off committees
because we don't like this thing they
said or that thing they said everyone
was saying it I'm sure you can find
videos of us talking about it on the
show right like everyone was saying it
once you start this Tit for Tat thing
Goose skander this is exactly what's
going to happen but Eric swalwell who is
a congressman from California
uh he's not happy about it so he tweeted
this
he said breaking representative Byron
Donalds admits on the readout that
speaker McCarthy is kicking me Adam
Schiff and ilhan off our communities
purely out of Vengeance now that's not
exactly what he said he didn't say he
was out of Vengeance he was saying if
you watch a full extended clip well
first off you guys did it so okay that
could be a little Vengeance related you
guys did it now we're gonna do it but
that there are plenty of reasons to do
it he went into the reasons about ilhan
Omar he didn't get a chance to do more
on Schiff who lied about everything
related to impeachments and could it be
that swalwell has done something
could it be that small well maybe did
something a couple years ago that would
be worthy of Kicking and kicked off the
intelligence committee and could it be
that everyone knows this and that there
was this uh little known I don't know
some would say quite Dapper uh online
video show host who talked to Kevin
McCarthy about that thing about two
years ago didn't swalwell sleep with the
Chinese spy or something I mean yes why
okay that's a good question I I want to
finish my eight pillars but let's talk
about this
what we know publicly a Chinese spy and
also remember Senator Feinstein we found
out later the driver of more than 10
years was a Chinese spy in Silicon
Valley there have been in pictures
together this woman a Chinese spy
creates a relationship with swallow well
Wednesdays and the city council
he runs for Congress
she helps she puts interns in his office
do you know how difficult it is to get
on the Intel committee when suavel was
put on the Intel committee they were in
the minority so they had some fewer
seats he was a sophomore getting burned
on the Intel committee he's kept on the
Intel committee now you know this you
put him on you did not know now you know
as a leader
okay if swallow was in the private
sector he could not get a security
clearance
because he had a relationship with a spy
but only in America can he be given the
Intel committee where he knows all the
secrets
but there's 200 other Democrats who are
qualified to be on that slot and she
keeps appointing what I know with what
the FBI told me
he should never be on Intel and Pelosi
reappointed an Intel
I don't understand this did you have you
said this to her yes
but this is worse I brought a motion to
the floor
to remove him from Intel put another
Democrat on the Democrats all defended
so you really got to understand the last
part there is key when the Republicans
were not in charge McCarthy was trying
to get rid of swallow as he just said
there he is now the speaker of the house
okay so that clip if if we had a decent
mainstream media and obviously we do not
that clip would be on CNN and across
every newspaper today and what they
would be doing either is if Kevin
McCarthy lied If he if everything he
just said there is a lie and what he's
claiming the FBI told him and all that
stuff and that that Fang Fang the the
Spy didn't staff uh swalwell's office
and all that stuff if it's all a lie
then why wouldn't you air that to
destroy Kevin McCarthy right you'd want
that clip out there my God Kevin
McCarthy is lying about what the FBI
told him and claiming that a Democrat uh
Congressman has been sleeping with the
Chinese spy or at least working with the
Chinese spy at some level but they're
not putting that on there and that tells
you that it's true right that is it
right there so okay you got it so was
this was this as swallow said was this
purely retribution or was it because
ilhan Omar is a noted anti-semite Adam
Schiff is the biggest liar in all of
congress with all the fake impeachments
in Russia Russia Russia and you were
banging a Chinese spy so this wasn't
about vengeance but um my theme here
today has been about the positive stuff
so I think you can see Byron Donald's on
his way telling the truth going into the
belly of the Beast blowing apart the
nonsense over there at MSNBC beautiful
Eric swalwell being exposed for the
fraud that he is and now these people
are being removed they are being taken
out of positions in power in government
so Republicans are getting balls and
guess what else that they are doing well
they're getting rid of those 87 000 IRS
agents I know the night is late
but when we come back our very first
bill
will appeal the funding for 87 000.
look they're going to offer up a whole
bunch of stuff I'm going to talk about
more of some of the things that they're
doing that I think are good in just a
moment they're gonna offer up a whole
bunch of stuff Congress can't just act
on itself Congress can put bills out
there then you need the Senate to vote
on these things and obviously the Senate
which is now you know it's basically a
49-49 tie with two Independents it's not
as if all of these things are going to
get passed right uh obviously but at
least they're trying right we're seeing
the glimmer of hope we're seeing people
go wait a minute wait a minute I have a
chance now McCarthy's going I have a
chance he had this fight right with his
more radical base is more radical let's
say or more more further conservative
something like that uh with his guys
they had the fight and maybe he's going
in now and we're going to do the right
thing so one of the things that I think
Republicans really would be good at is
putting out a positive message what is
it that we stand for well McCarthy's on
that too we're going to pass bills to
fix the nation's earns challenges from
wide open Southern borders it's American
last energy policies to woke
indoctrination in our schools
pretty good border we all think a border
is good right even Joe Biden now
apparently thinks that a border is good
American Energy that would be nice that
might help our economic situation
getting the woke stuff out all good
again I don't have any Illusions they
will fail on some of this stuff the
Senate is not going to go along with all
this stuff but they're trying and when
good people try you gotta back them uh I
don't want to say good people when
someone's out there trying like hearing
what the issues are and then voted in
and then they're they're just at least
are showing you a glimmer of hope
they're trying to say bail boy I'm gonna
actually go to the promised land then
you gotta you gotta help them get there
they're shifting they're going on
offense and they're taking No
Reservations about it like they're
really just going for it another thing
that they're going to do this is
absolutely spectacular and I said to my
guys right before we started we're gonna
go and check it out they're going to
open up Congress again so that people
you the average American citizen can go
into Congress and watch them debate that
is something that Congress got rid of a
long time ago and then because of kovid
they've they all vote electronically on
these things so they don't even show up
anymore well guess what they're going to
open the people's house back up you know
what's the difference now this is
probably more people in the public
that's ever been in the Capitol in the
last two years we've now opened the
doors I want to invite everyone who's
listening if you've ever dreamed of
coming to DC come to DC and you know
what you can sit in the gallery and you
can watch us debate you can see your
government at work because this is your
house this is your government and we
have just now empowered you even greater
than ever before so that brings
accountability
great cool transparency watch them
debate see the good parts see the bad
stuff see how the sausage is made we're
gonna go we're gonna go do it I'm gonna
take my team and do it I'm sure we can
get some interviews while we're down
there but that is a beautiful thing and
sunlight is the best disinfectant that's
Democratic that's a democracy in action
so what else are they doing well they're
talking about what the vision is border
energy get rid of woke stuff we're going
to get more people we're going to be
more transparent more people can come
watch us debate that's pretty good and
guess what they're also ending some of
the covid nonsense we got a tweet by
Ryan savadra he's a daily wire
journalist breaking the Pentagon has
ended it's covid vaccine mandate for the
U.S military after Kevin McCarthy
demanded that it be pulled out of the
defense the National Defense
authorization act that was approved last
month yeah good more good stuff it is a
freaking damn shame and I would argue
actually a crime that we demanded that
our members of the military have to be
vaccinated and I think there there
hopefully will be hell to pay maybe not
on this Earth but in a on another plane
for some of these people that that
forced all this stuff the idea that we
took our youngest healthiest people and
forced them to be vaccinated and now I
don't have to belabor the point about
heart conditions and all of the other
vaccine injuries and everything else and
football players having strokes and
people dropping dead here and there and
all kinds of stuff all kinds of stuff
really crazy stuff it's horrible that we
did it in the first place but okay
Republicans doing the right thing and
now it's been reversed we got more what
else are the Republicans planning to do
uh hear from the New York Post House
votes to establish special panels to
investigate China and weaponization of
the federal government all right
investigating China that would be good
you know when I mentioned Dylan Mulvaney
before Dylan Mulvaney is the dude who
dresses like a chick pretends to be a
woman having periods and I guess he
she's on Tick Tock and they invited a
whole bunch of tick-tockers to the uh to
the White House and they sat down with
Biden and she she he asked them about
trans things and Biden said it was a
moral imperative that young people be
able to chop off their nuts and that
whole thing uh well they're all using
tick tock on their phones and Tick Tock
is known to be a Chinese spy device when
you put that on your phone they have
access to all of your stuff the feed
when you're on Tick Tock I don't have it
on my phone uh when they when the feed
when you're on Tick Tock uh in America
they show you a very different feed they
force the woke stuff down 14 year olds
brains all day long I'm a boy I'm a girl
all this crazy stuff while in China they
show them how to build things and they
show them videos about engineering and
Mathematics and Science and a whole
bunch more so they're going to look into
China that seems pretty good uh they're
going to look into the weaponization of
the government this is the big one this
is the big one because if we cannot
figure out what happened related to
these Twitter files I mean we know what
happened but if nobody is going to pay a
price for any of it then it will always
happen again and here's where I want to
put a a sort of pause on this whole
thing it's really good to have these
committees it's good to have some
hearings it's good to get people to
testify under oath and and hopefully get
to some level of truth but all of it's a
show unless something happens because of
it so Republicans here's my challenge to
you McCarthy who I've interviewed and
Jim Jordan who we're about to show I've
interviewed a couple times it's not just
about the show anymore you guys got to
do something with this stuff
since you might check out Jim Jordan on
the floor yesterday talking about what
they are gonna do a ploy
it's not a ploy when the Department of
Justice treats parents as terrorists
moms and dads who are simply showing up
at a school board meeting to advocate
for their son or daughter a place not a
ploy when the FBI pays Twitter 3 million
dollars not one not two three million
dollars two censor American citizens
it's not a ploy when the Department of
Homeland Security tries to set up a
disinformation governance board because
we all know that the Department of
Homeland Security can tell what's good
speech and what is bad speech what's
Miss I mean you got to be kidding me the
former Democrat chair of the
intelligence committee pressured Twitter
to censor a journalist
you've got to be kidding me that this is
the most important this is about the
First Amendment something you guys used
to care about and I'd actually hoped we
could get bipartisan agreement on
protecting the First Amendment the five
rights we enjoy As Americans under the
First Amendment your right to practice
your faith your right to assemble right
to petition the government freedom of
press freedom of speech every single
one's been attacked in the last two
years there were the government was
telling people they couldn't go to
church just a few years ago we want to
focus on that because we want it all to
stop we want the double standard to stop
this idea that if oh if you're a
pro-life activist you're going to get
your door kicked in you're going to get
arrested and handcuffed in front of your
seven kids and your spouse for simply
praying in front of abortion clinic and
telling the guy who was harassing your
son to knock it off you're going to have
the FBI raid your home but the the
protests that went on at Supreme Court
Justices homes in the aftermath of the
leak of the Dobb's opinion oh no problem
there Americans are sick and tired of it
and what we want we don't want to go
after anyone we just wanted to stop and
we want to respect the First Amendment
to the Constitution that the greatest
country in the world has that's what
this committee is all about and that's
what we're
that's what we're going to focus on
testify brother look this is the chance
you think they're getting some balls
they're growing some balls right in
front of our faces
and that's a disturbing image you're
right it's a little early in the day for
that sort of thing but it's happening
right now so this is why I'm saying we
have to show these guys you're going to
have some support along the way uh by
the way Jim Jordan right there from Ohio
uh he was one of the members of the
House Freedom caucus with the guy that
you might know this guy Ron DeSantis so
do you think that maybe some of the
ideas that they were talking about you
know seven years ago as young
Congressman finally now they're on the
other side you've gotta you've got
DeSantis run in Florida like a champ and
then you've got Republicans in charge of
the house and maybe that courage starts
to spread maybe people start looking
around and going holy cow I'm not alone
and holy cow those rights that Jim
Jordan talked about there right to
assemble right to free speech all of
those things they have been trampled on
and enough is enough so then what
happens courage and goodness and doing
the right thing it starts becoming
contagious and it's happening across the
country right now here's something
you're probably not going to see on CNN
tonight Iowa governor Kim Reynolds uh
who I think is absolutely fantastic she
strikes me as the type of person that
could definitely be in the race uh I
don't know that she's going to run but
like could definitely be like a VP uh
situation for her uh here she is
announcing a new school choice bill in
Iowa my school choice bill will create
create education savings accounts for
families who choose to send their child
to a private school
the state will contribute
7598 dollars to that account which is
the amount of funding the state provides
for each child who attends a public
school
for students currently attending a
private school the plan will be phased
in focusing first on the families with
the lowest income levels and in three
years every family will have a choice in
education and no child will be limited
by income or zip code
really think how fantastic this is what
they are saying is right now the way the
government operates in every state
government basically operates like this
we get a certain amount of budget at the
beginning of the year and we put all of
that budget towards public education
doesn't matter if you're getting a good
education doesn't matter where you live
or anything else here's what it is it's
sort of a one fits all approach to
everything now instead of funding the
system which is the way we've always
done it they are going to fund students
you as the parent will get that credit
okay and then you will say all right
what do I want to do how are the public
schools in this District that we live in
oh they're pretty good okay that's fine
we're going to send them there oh the
public schools are no good we're going
to send them to this private school or
this charter school maybe we'll have to
make up some money ourselves right
because the seven thousand dollar credit
isn't going to cover everything but
we're getting a chance to to do a little
bit more be a little bit more involved
and make sure that our kids aren't being
indoctrinated going to bad schools that
are not safe or secure or whatever it
might be this is a beautiful model that
for as far as I can tell it is first
happening in Iowa Kim Reynolds deserves
a lot of credit for this we don't even
have this in Florida yet I think it
could be on the way now we happen to
have excellent public schools in Florida
because DeSantis has removed so much
much of the woke stuff that perhaps it's
a little less necessary here but this is
a great model and what is that that's
the experiment of democracy oh it's
going to start working in Iowa and then
once it's working in Iowa people in
other states are going to be like hey I
want that school choice too and guess
what speaking of that experiment well
DeSantis takes the woke stuff out of the
schools here in in Florida he fights
Disney does that wins by 20 points so
you know what's going on in Arkansas
Arkansas well new incoming Governor
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she as I'm sure
you remember was the White House
spokesman the first White House spokes
or no she was after Spicer right I think
the second White House spokesman after
Sean Spicer for Donald Trump uh well now
she just got inaugurated and she's going
right after the education system and
she's going to to make sure parents have
a little something to do with what their
kids are learning
parents
so let's give parents a greater role in
education
including
including the right to choose the school
that's best for their child whether it
is public private or parochial
you see how beautiful this is guys it's
it's infectious in a good way a good
kind of infection right when you do the
right thing now it's starting time and
this is why when we finish the show
yesterday and I was just thinking about
this Florida versus Cali thing I was
like no I want to show people that it
can happen elsewhere and then Byron
Donald's blows up on the national scene
then we get all of this great stuff
coming out of Iowa coming out of
Arkansas and it's going to keep
happening while at the same time the
dingbat Democrats Kathy Hotel up in New
York right now you know what she's
working on she's trying to get
gas-powered stoves to be banned and
she's trying to change all of these
crazy regulations related to building
they want zero emission buildings by
2025 I don't know if she knows that it's
already 2023 and that buildings are
being built right now and they maybe
can't change the code I know she doesn't
really care about that because Democrats
are only good at destroying things not
actually building things literally or
figuratively
ah
what Sarah Huckabee Sanders was talking
about there is in stark contrast to
former Arkansas governor her predecessor
ASA Hutchinson who caved on trans
surgery for minors and a whole bunch of
other stuff so Arkansas getting stronger
right now Iowa getting stronger right
now what are place what places are not
getting stronger New York Cali Michigan
masks there are kids in schools in masks
in Ann Arbor Michigan right now but
Republicans are getting a backbone like
a ramrod and how are they doing it well
because of a blueprint
and where did that blueprint start it
started right here in the Free State of
Florida because one guy said no no no no
I don't like you fouchy and we ain't
turning this place into fauciville
here's Ron DeSantis yesterday
Florida over the last couple years I
mean it's just crazy the number of
people that are down here at any given
time of course people moving here but
also visiting here and we were really I
mean by far when you start talking about
like 20 20 21 I mean we were number one
destination by far and so that has
helped really fill our coffers and we're
even in most recent month I think we
were uh 450 million dollars higher in
Revenue than than was anticipated and so
you know those are things as you budget
that's money coming in you know not
because there's taxes are changing it's
just because there's more economic
activity uh in the economy is growing
and so that would not have been possible
you know if we had turned Florida into a
foucheville it would not have been
possible and so we had to make sure to
do the right thing yeah you do the right
thing and next thing you know you've got
governors in Iowa that are doing the
right thing governors in Arkansas that
are doing the right thing and then they
just start realizing boy I'm not the
only one that has to step up I think
part of what's going on here and that's
why I always talk about it at a
spiritual level it's like people are
afraid of being the guy who steps up and
and by the way being the guy who steps
up not only is it not easy it doesn't
always end well I guess in probably most
cases it doesn't end well to be the guy
who really says to the system no right
the buck stops with me I will not
participate in the lie anymore but now
he's done it and now we're seeing it
exported and now at the not only at the
state level but we're seeing the
national Republicans and again they're
not going to get all this stuff done
they're not going to get it all done but
there's a marker you can feel a shift
happening there is a cultural
underpinning it's more than policy it's
the rhetoric that they're after they're
going after the things that should be
gone after one of the other things that
they're going after it's not just the
Oak stuff here and it's not just what's
going on in our schools and the
neo-racism and all that DeSantis is also
going after and this may be the toughest
of all of them he's going after the
globalists the Davos crowd the world
economic Forum crowd the China crowd
these people who do not believe in
individual rights not only they not
believe in individual rights they don't
believe in in states rights and I mean
states by nation state they don't
believe that the United States should
have a different set of autonomous rules
than say China or Mexico or Sweden or
elsewhere here's the scientists going
after the big boys they do this thing in
Davos they're doing it next week all
these Elites come in
um you know the world economic forum and
basically
um you know their vision is they run
everything and everybody else is just
like a surf like a peasant they say
they're going after energy ESG all these
other things and you see the Biden
Administration once the the next gas
stoves are you kidding me like we need I
want guestives I mean imagine like you
how many people had the hurricane come
through didn't have power right away but
were able to turn on uh some so you
cannot go down this road but that's
exactly uh what they want to do and it's
really weakening uh Western Society
Western values but underlying a lot of
that is the CCP you know those people
are there they're Elites but you know XI
is is really um is really kind of the
the puppet behind the curtain on a lot
of this stuff so very very problematic I
think in the direction they want to go
and what I've said in Florida is is that
type of stuff coming out of Davos those
policies are Dead on Arrival in the
state
talk about the globalist intersect but
just a quick point on this on this gas
range thing that they want to get rid of
how stupid and ridiculous this is you
know so we moved to Florida last year as
you guys know and actually where we live
there are we don't have a gas line to
the house so the stove here was electric
meaning that everyone here has electric
stoves or you can bring in you know your
own propane tank and then do your thing
just sort of off off the grid so to
speak
um David is a great chef and I love to
cook and we had its electric stove
nobody who ever has cooked there is no
Chef in any restaurant anywhere in the
world who wants to cook on an electric
stove you can't get a good feel for the
heat it's just not you know you want to
see that flame right it's real now
it'll make you a better Chef it'll make
you better cook your food will taste
better you'll be happier when you're
sitting there because everyone likes
good food but they want to take even
that away because they are actually
anti-human it has nothing to do with
fossil fuels they want everything to be
endless misery that is controlled by the
government that's just my quick thought
on that anyway so we had to pay to have
the electric stove removed and we got a
propane tank outside and we buried it
and now we're we're doing it with gas
and you ain't coming for it AOC or Nancy
Pelosi or Joe Biden or any of you freaks
anyway as per the sort of world
government that is trying to push all of
this stuff and how it is connected with
China and maybe did China release covet
on the world so that all of us would put
all of these authoritarian policies in
place to ourselves instead of having to
invade us with soldiers they invaded us
with bad ideas and with Tick Tock and
they got us to basically bow to them
by nothing you're going to get a cold
and then we were like ah I'll stay in my
house for two years up and the known
world okay
uh he's right he's right and we can
fight it and now the Republicans
partly because of that Jim Jordan guy
are going to fight it they are going to
look into weaponization of government
which is happening because of these
organizations and they are going to look
into how China is affecting our
government and this is all good stuff uh
one of the other good things that's
happening here is that the the Democrat
Party in Florida has been absolutely
obliterated
absolutely obliterated and uh the head
of the democratic party he has resigned
and DeSantis had a little something to
say about that in terms of the
resignation you know of the other
party's chairman uh there ain't many as
many Democrats around as there used to
be in the State of Florida and we had
something to do with that in November of
2022
by the way if there were good Democrats
meaning if they were old school
Democrats who just had a slightly
different policy position oh no we do
want to do a little bit more with the
government because we think the
government's kind of functional and this
that or the other thing it's like then
it would be okay but they just don't
exist anymore and we have to stop
pretending they exist which is why as I
often say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
but in most of these states you probably
should be a republican so let's just tie
this whole thing together right now
there is something good happening here
and it's emanating here but now it's
being copied throughout the states and
at the federal level when you look at
what Ron DeSantis did here in Florida
and then you take a guy like Byron
Donalds who is a congressman here in
Florida right you can you can sort of
see it with Byron Donalds he's getting
some juice because he's looking at
DeSantis going man you're you're doing
the right thing I will do the right
thing and I'll go into the buzz saw with
the media and I will fight these morons
and I will I will stand up for what I
believe in in the face of the
Ridiculousness of people like Joy Reed
right Byron Donald's by the way he gave
the speech on Election night you guys
saw it we live streamed it he gave the
speech on Election night before DeSantis
spoke so that it seems like he's he's on
his rise for many many good reasons so
you take the the DeSantis Byron Donald's
connection then you take the DeSantis
Jim Jordan connection as I said before
they were both part of the freedom
caucus years ago when they were both
young congressmen then you could talk
about what's going on with uh Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and Kim Reynolds from
Iowa and Arkansas respectively uh I was
at a Governor's conference about a month
ago with a bunch of other influencers
and Kim Reynolds and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and a bunt Uh Kevin Stitt from
uh from Montana uh Oklahoma sorry and a
bunch of other Governors
um and guess what how those ideas are
getting spread across the nation Billy
from Tennessee and others so desantis's
ideas on education let's get the woke
stuff out Sarah Sarah Huckabee Sanders
doing it right now DeSantis on vaccine
mandates seems to be happening
throughout all the the red States right
now and most importantly the spine
as Joe Biden would say the backbone like
a ramrod but why are they being
influenced is it just is it because they
like Rhonda said this oh he's a nice guy
he's a nice guy his wife's pretty no
it's because the proof is in the pudding
and that is the pudding that they want
to bring to their states because
everybody likes pudding whether it is in
the form of a small cup or a pudding pop
or whatever else it might be just real
quick before we uh before we wrap up and
of course we are doing a post game show
at reubenreport.locals.com I wanted to
show you the results of the house
election results in 2022 because you
know we were expecting this big red wave
and it didn't quite get there meaning
that what you're seeing there on the
right GOP 222 and Dems 213. Republicans
have control ass but if you just look at
it geographically we are largely a red
country right we are largely largely a
red country and the key thing is that
even though they didn't pick up the the
you know 30 seats that was the idea they
got enough to get control of the house
they got the extra nine seats that they
needed and then here is the Senate
situation which is a 49-49 tie and of
course there are two Independents right
now so the Republicans actually lost one
after War uh Warnock beat out Herschel
Walker but let's just compare that and I
think this is the final piece of the
puzzle let's just compare that to what's
going on in Florida because everything
that I've laid out here it's like oh
it's being replicated right the
blueprint is being replicated this is
beautiful well here's Florida
I haven't seen that much red since the
red wedding at the Game of Thrones uh
DeSantis won 60 of the vote uh Charlie
Crist got 40 I mean that's 20 percentage
points if you're doing math at home
that's about a million and a half votes
uh and just what was it four years ago
he only won by 30 000 votes to a guy who
turned out to be a uh not a crack addict
I'm always thinking of crack when I
think of Democrats a meth addict uh yes
that's right a meth addict so what is
going to happen what is what is going to
happen as the worm turns here what is
what is going to happen as we start
seeing red States flourish and and
Republican let's say conservative
messaging working you are going to see
more and more hysterical nonsense from
the corporate press yesterday there was
a piece written by a guy by the name of
Peter Baker in the New York Times I
don't know much about him but he
obviously is he's just a Democrat
operative who works at the New York
Times which is just a propaganda Outlet
right it's American Pravda so so they
wrote this piece on scary Ron DeSantis
and well just take a look Trump elevated
media bashing into a high art for
Republicans but ahead of the next
presidential race DeSantis and others
are taking a more radical approach not
just attacking non-partisan news outlets
but ignoring them all together so
somehow leave this up for just a moment
somehow
not talking to these people is more
radical than attacking them attacking
them used to be the worst thing now
ignoring them is even worse than
attacking them the reason I wanted Conor
to leave this up if you look at the
bottom there so what you're seeing those
numbers that you're seeing down there
are this this tweet that this guy put
out got 1.2 million views but it was
ratioed into high hell what ratioed
means for those of you that are not
playing along on the Twitter all day
long God bless you what ratio means is
when you see that first bubble there
that little talky bubble that means that
2612 people commented on it and if you
look at the comments it's everybody just
down this guy he's an idiot he's a hack
he's a partisan stupid like come on man
it's so obvious what you guys are doing
and it only got 713 retweets and 1 313
likes so that is what we call a ratio if
you are a creature of the internet he
got ratioed into high hell which is
another reason that these people wanted
censorship on Twitter because they're
always getting ratioed when we can see
through their nonsense I mean just the
the very premise of the thing Trump was
the worst because he fought with the
media this guy won't talk to us and not
talking to us is way worse because we
want attention
guys stick around for a post-game show
which we're going to put up at
reubenreport.locals.com in just a moment
uh if you haven't subscribed yet please
do it rumble.com Reuben report my
interview with Tulsi gabbard is up
across platforms right now we leave you
with Karin Jean-Pierre in meme form and
I'll see in a couple minutes with some
uh some corrections some questions some
comments and other such things see ya
and I've said this many times before we
do not politicize the Department of
Justice that is something that the
president said during the campaign that
is something that the president said in
his early days of of being in the White
House and that continues to be true
foreign
[Music]